de
kırmızı konumda olmak gerçekten ve onu
ol dayı Amerika'da kor
gençlik korosu kurduk Büyük başarılar
vesaire böyle hani bir okunan yazılan
Yani
şey yok oğlum öyle
2013'te Cumhuriyet tarihinin en büyük
yaşama modeline çok güzel bekliyoruz Ne
ürünleri söyle çok zor
geçebilirim kızmam iletebilirim
çocuklar gençler bir koronun parçası
Gece sonra buraya bıraktı Mimar Sinan
kişiliğimiz Cihan Amerika'ya gitmeye
Aslında halklar insanlar Korel ince bir
meslek kapısı olarak yaklaşma benim için
olimpiyatları'ndan 3 altın madalya
çok şeyden bahsediyoruz bu dönemde işte
bütün bu zorluğun hiçbir şey anlamadım
da Macaristan böyle bir yolculuk 100 bin
onlarla işte birçok lise ders esmerlerde
veriyor birlikte kişileri yapabildiğini
Hepsini bir arada olduğu bir yer mısın
şeyler hepsini bir şekilde yapıyorum
Umuyorum ki bu hayalimiz gerçek olur hep
elde ettiğim Az daha kurduk içinden
Güzel Sanatlar Üniversitesi Devlet
karar verdi eğitimine devam etmek için
değerleri bu insani değerleri
yıkılayım öğretebilirim öğrencilerin
birilerinin burada kalması gerekiyor
çok zor mu Bence değil
oluyor birbirimizi dinlemeyi birbirimizi
bir şeydi herkese Aşık istedim aynı
halk hareketi olarak gösterilen gezi
noktası özü
Konservatuvarı kompozisyon şekilde
Kendi kendine çıkıp Bahçede top
İtalya ve Macaristan da çok başarılı
olarak bir konuda şarkı söyleyerek
koyu bana devretti Ben sorumluluğu
ben şu an zamanla Yarışıyor çünkü ama
beraber daha güçlü bir şeyler çıkara
Euro'luk bir bütçe
daha çok işte gençlikte ergenlikten
ve başka bir dil konuşuluyor Bir de
korlar doğdu yıllar içerisinde
öğrenebilirim Yani gerçekten
şeyler anlamaya başladım ama eğlenceli
yarışmalarda Çamlık söyledi kötüler
benimseyerek queue sevmeyi paylaşmayı
amacı birileri burada kalmasaydı
dünya değişiyor hep beraber görüyoruz
oynuyorum yüzme bir Lego işte bir
beraber görüştüm Türkiye'ye konuların
ve biz bunu
Son dakikaya kadar yeni sponsor
şekilde hareketlerinde Senin
ben işte bu olsun matematiği bıraktım
yürüsünler o değerleri kendilerine
temsilcilerinden festivaller dünyanın
bölmeye başladım bir yıl sonra bir
daha fazla anlamaya birbirimize tolerans
daha sonra da niye geldin niye
bir şey varmış böyle biz bunun sonucunda
gerçekten mutluluk veriyor yani hayatına
bildiğinin bir ortak zevki dinlen Çok
Geldiğimiz noktada dünyanın en önemli
aldık müzik grubumuz vardı hatta
Alacağız da küçüklükten gelen bir bugün
değil gevşek şişkinliği doğru
protestolarında çok spontane bir şekilde
arkadaşları bile olmamıştı hiç bu tam
düşünüyorum Şimdi beş yıl önce Optik
paylaşabileceğim bu kadar düzgün
bir tane Arif olmazsa yani çok aşırı
yayıldığını çocuklarımızın gençlerimizin
arayışları vesaire çok ilgilendi görüşme
Yapay Zeka lardan bahsediyoruz artık
katarak
müzik okumaya başladım sonunda bıraktım
Seçkin festivalleri derken şöyle ilginç
bütün olsaydım şeyler var ya danspor şu
göstermeyi yardımlaşmayı dayanışmayı
odanın biz üniversite yıllarımıza yapmak
keyifli bir şeyler başarı ayrı bir şey
son ilginç bir video başında bu
bilgiler alıyorum sizden
ekranlı karşısından bir Aslında sağlaya
konularda şarkı söyleyerek büyük
durdum Çünkü konu sürekli yoğunlaşıyor
Aslında kendinize bir yer bulduk orada
gidiyorsun arada diğer var mı bir buçuk
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi'nde tanışmam da
Bence herkesin olmayan Adalar kalkmış
hissetmeye insan olduğumuzu Aslında
belgesel Ben Bir bölüm daha birkaç ay
karakterimizin şekillendiği elimizden
festivallerinde Türkiye'ye geldiği ilk
ciddi rahatsızlığım vardı Ee bunu da ben
şuraya gelmişti biraz zor bir çocukluk
Şimdi hâlâ öğrenciyim geri döndüm
sevmeyi paylaşmayı
bir gelişme oldu ben
bu hiçbirinden Hobi olarak görmedim
aslında öyle olmuştu ben nokta benziyor
oldu artık öyle son aşamasına geldik
hamilelik döneminde bu görüşmeleri
güzel bir şey diyeceğim ve
çok daha farklı bir şey oldu Tabii ki
zorunda kaldık Dolayısıyla 2011/2 varlar
başladık zaten metal Özden bir şey
uzaklaştığımız Türkiye'den dünyanın
kez ve kurula başarıyla temsil etme
birlikte şarkı söylemek ve çok güzel
böyle edilmesiyle oluşturduğu İşte o
ve çok iyi gidiyor biz işte bu beş kişi
eğitimi orkestra şefi lisans
bildiğiniz görüyoruz bir koroya ait
oldu aslında diyebilirim o zamanları
önce farkettim bilgisayarda öyle bir şey
Koray'la
Ben acile çalışıyoruz ve hastaları bizi
köşelerini Her birimizin bambaşka
oluyor cesaret katıyor bu yapabildiğim
Tamam dedik Ah bunu yaptık imzalatılacak
aslında hiçbir zaman yani benim için
Aslında bağımsız bir yolculuk Bu
birçok sesli komut düzenlemesinin bir
şerefine nail olmuş ve tüm Türkiye
yaptık biz bir buçuk yıl boyunca ki hala
birlikte bir şeyi aynı şeyleri aşka
dönemin büyük bir yarışması önemli bir
Benim için çok zor geçtim bazen enerji
farklı yerlerinden insanlarla bir araya
geliyor yavaş yavaş
hatırlayacak ve hatırlatacak şeyleri
başladık alttan girmiş olduk büyük
zaman
katılabilecek Festivali araştırırken
böyle en çok detaylı dağıtırlar masamda
olunca bir koronun parçası olunca bir
oldu ve bunu paylaş Ve bu çok zor
öğrencisiyim yani Üniversite öğrencileri
hepsi lâyıkıyla yapıldığı zaman
hassasiyetleri farklı uçları varoş
neredeyse bir hafta sonra Bir Haber
kavgalardan savaşlardan yok işte döviz
ekonomisini sevdirmiş ve bünyesinde şu
başarısı hissini duyuyorsun
yapmak istedim mi Evet
geldiğimiz
zorluklarla şimdi gittik dünya kor
türkünün çoksesli versiyonunun
size artık yani o kapatıyoruz doğru
devam ediyoruz ev 1500 kişilikli
işkolları değişiyor
amatör müzik grupları yarışmasında bizim
dünyanın Zirvesi dedikleri bir Festivali
Ama bu aslında çok sesli koro müziği
çok kötü bazen Siz ettim kendime ama
dört yıl üniversitede çatısı altında
bu bilgilerin sen dahil olabilirsin ve
var saldırı selamları var aramızda Ama
kola şarkı söyleyerek ve yetişince
ufkumuzu geliştirdiği ve vizyonumuz un
Özümse ye bunlarıda ilimize kazarak
Geldi maalesef işte Çok ani gelişen
yangınların olduğu Selin olduğu
Olimpiyatları'na ikincilikler güçlükler
konumuzla katılmıştı koyu tıfıllar
karşılık olan ve bana Keyif veren şeyler
Elimizi biraz yuvarlamayı bazı ödünler
dünya değişiyor zaten bunun önünde kimse
milyonlarca insan hep birlikte
hissediyordum ki artık sadece hani benim
kurundan olumsuz şeylerden bahsetmek
v2011 itibariyle şu an 10. yılımızı
de gelin oraya bir e-posta göndermiştim
içselleştirme bilmem de ki en önemli şey
neden bunları yapıyoruz Evet bunu beş
dönemlerde Çünkü eviniz çok da aldık ama
mimari kristal olabilir Size yardımcı
an bine yakın yaşları olmakta 65
sen de onlar gibi baka Biliyorsun
toplulukla 78 fark toplulukla bir buçuk
buradaki bütün insanlar bilmeden Bir
vererek Tamam renk lerimizden hiçbir şey
yetiştiğini zaman çok daha farklı bir
kazandım ardından Avusturya etmek
olarak orada bir oldu
aslında
Aslında bir anlamda oluştu çok önemli
o yüzden ve bu değerlerini E bu
de bir sorumluluk bana verildiği zaman o
2011'de dünya şampiyonu olunca çok daha
bitirdik ve 11. yılınız dayız
hayatında 7 yaşında kilise korosunda
söylemesiyle nasıl yüreklendirici nasıl
Olamayacağız biz kaldık bütün
duramaz
aslında ben de uymamış şarkısı çok
yıl önceden bir röportajım var bence
istedik O azıcık videonun başında
yerine gerçekten aşktan sevgiden
masadayken aktif amatör koro şarkıcısı
kaybetmeden yani
için güzel şeyler de ben sadece işe
bir Köprüsü ve Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
ama herkeste böyle bir merak etme endişe
hiçbir konu şehri işte mest Ecir ya da
toplumu motorlu dünyayı değiştirebilir
birileri burada kaldı zamanda İşte o
ay boyunca çalışmalarımıza ara vermeden
hayvan vb.nin bu şekilde devam etmeye
paylaştık bilmediğim şeyler öğrendim ben
hazırlığımız var veya size kalmış İki
hatta böyle prova için gittiğimizde
hızlı cevap gelmişti harika
şarkı söylemeye başladım ve yedi yıl
dini parayla oradan duyabiliriz en iyi
gördüğünüz Metro videosunu çıkıştır Aslı
çevrimiçi platformda Bu çalışmaları
tanıtımı için çok değerli yer Öyleyse ne
dolayısıyla da Konu şehriyle öyle
gidip geliyorum yani çalışıyorum Tamam
gevşek vermişim Çünkü gereksiz ben olsun
barıştan dostluktan kardeşlikten
moral verici ve o çok zor zamanda
zaman 70 milyon muyuz düşündüm Şimdi
barındıran bir o kadar yolu yine bizim
hafta ne yapacağız ne edeceğiz derken o
farklılıklarımızı birer dezavantajlı
performanslar çok başarılı ama henüz bu
Avusturya'da dünya konu şampiyonasına
Biz ne iş yapacağız Ne yapacağız Dünya
Sevgi barış dolu bir nesil ver oluşan
kadar söyledim Bir yandan işte ilk
başımıza oluşturmuştu oradaki diğer
Türkiye'nin çoksesli koruyu çok sesli
başladı Ben de yepyeni bir sayfa açtık
sürdürdüm çok da yoğun bir programla ve
işte Bir müzisyen ocağın hayali olmuş
cumartesi nöbetten çıkıyorum pazarda
yapacağım yapacağım da her İki seçenek
bahsedeceğimiz çok güzel Dünyamız olacak
80-85 artık neyse bir toplu olarak
aslında herkes nasıl bir araya getirecek
zaman korku türünün ile beni vazgeçirmek
gerek yani dokuz sorunsuz ve Hitler'in
katıldık son sorumuzu bulduk o videonun
polifolia seviyesinden bizim Festivali
nereye gidiyor bu da tutmamız gereken
okuldayım ve kendimi bildim bileli de
Şimdi senin daha önce yaşamadığı bir
değil değil Eğer sevdiğin Lig olarak
aileden geçmiş belki bir film üzerinde
ilgi prova var diyorum kelime tekrar
bıraktım kendine birisi psikoloji
işte serkezi seçme yaptım çok küçük bir
koro müziğinin bambaşka bir Belki de
o dönemde yaptığımız görüşmeler var bir
yarışmacı gruplar o sizde burada
benim üzerine çok erken yaşta iki buçuk
elimize çok teşekkür et
bir toplum önce kendi ülkesinde ardından
için yemeğe çıkardı ben işte 24
seviyesini görmüyoruz size diye Ben
oradan buraya atıyorum işte halk
ve konu şarkıcısına dokunmuş olan
olabileceğini gördük O müziğin Aslında
diyelim matematikte
gönül bu Zenginliğin yarattığı Harmandan
öğrendiklerim Yani bir parçası çıkmış
ülkece bir konu olabilmek Aslında ne
farklı insanlarla olmak farklı
tabanı aldığım her geliyorum da
yaşında kendi kendine Okuma yazmayı
süreç içinde birinciye devam ettirmek ve
kovaya ait olmak bir korunun parçası
sayesinde gidecek Oraya bütün Saydım
vizyonunu tanıdığı vesiledir biz onu bir
bir şey var aslında işte onu da zaten
spinalis misiniz Ben de sonra göremedik
grupla başladık dokuz kişi başladık
anlamına etmediğini görmüş olduk tüm
cevabımı aldım oturmuştum bir yıl sonra
tüm dünyayı değiştirebilir Gel bakalım
gibi hissediyor
zaten lisede sayısal bölüm okumuştum
oyunları modernas bilim olmuşuz ortalığı
sürdürebilen insanlar enerji İşte bu
yaşındayım o zaman ve
insanlarla beraber aynı dedesi olmasa da
sonra beş kişiye düştük o beş kişiyle
keyif almayı öğreniyoruz aslında hep
öğrenmişim o üzerine tabi ailenin
olmak ne demek Bence hamilelik döneminde
demek bu niye bunun peşinden koşuyoruz
sağlıklı olması aslında herkesi biraz da
borçlarla büyük risklerle gittiğiniz o
dünyadan izle bu notaları istediler
onları ben arkadaşlar Boğaziçi
desteklediği kurulmasından itibaren
aynı dili konuşabildiğini insanlarla
başladım bir yandan da müzik bölümünü
yolculuk tanesi çok sancılı olmuştur Bu
videonun sonu nasıl bitiyor öyle de
çok güzel anlattılar
o yarım saate zorunda elimize
fotoğraf çektiren resimde bakalım bak
aynı ortamı paylaşmak ve aynı şeyi
okul takımlarında oynuyorum Yani evde
giderli kurduğumuz huzur barış kardeşlik
Üniversitesi'nde alayım hakkında vardı
işte ilk yılımızda çok önemli bir
destek olduğu üniversite kurumları
dünyanın farklı merkezlerinde bazıları
korkutucu yaparken Biz ne öğreniyoruz
fikirleri haliyle işte geleceğin parlak
tam gün boyunca İstanbul'un bütün
kapatalım hoş geldiniz Bu içinde acayip
Amerika'daki kol olimpiyatlarından sonra
olsa rahatlattı Bence daha böyle sana
dahi bulması hissediyor onda Şimdi izle
arada tabii ki maddi açılan iki dünya
bir korku olduğunu öğrendim cihaz konusu
yani nerede olsam Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
telefonlarda Herkes sandıkların işte
yani ben de sizler geçtiğini hissettim
kültürleri sesi projesiyle Tüm
olduğumu düşünüyorum Şey Çok güzeller
bu duygular
Merkezi yerlerinde şarkı söyleyerek
uluslararası festivalde iki tane gümüş
konuşmak hoşuna gidiyor
Aslında konumuz yaparken Arkadaşlar biz
aynı e-postanıza Festivali direktöründen
gelirdim çatla bırakırdım hemen böyle
kendi koreografileri ile Bu eseri İşte o
sevgi dolu bir toplum Hayal Aslında mı
şampiyonluğu kazandık
iyidir ama ne okuyacağım hiç düşünmedim
türkiye'ye yayılmış farklı dillerde
bilim insanı gibi böyle şeyler hafif
aslında bir olduğunu hatırladım
geçirdiğimiz o günün sonucunda o videoda
ya biraz konusundan biri bir
böyle nasıl desem yani yanındaki de
diploma kazandık ardından Pro ilerledik
hissettiklerimi daha böyle Aslı Hayat
hissetmek ister edebilmek ve
ödevlerimi hızlıca bitirdik Yarım saat
kimlerden ne kadar para bulabilirsiniz
Aynen öyle de gelelim vardır ama
hem hayalini kurduğumuz ve birlikte
bir mesaj masasiz Sen farkında değildi
konuların kurulmasına öncülük etmiş tüm
Türkiye'ye döndük çalışacak iş yerimiz
Çapulcu musun vay vay diye birçoğumuzun
açıkçası çok öğrense demiş o dönemlerde
Devam Ediyor Böyle dışarıda böyle
ve biz çok sesli Korolar da bunun
içinde belki en fazla kendini dışarı
dinletilerinde denk gelmiştim onların
borç alıyoruz yani neyse o 100 bin
gider ve yatırımlar üzerine devam ediyor
yakışıklı bizdende habersiz bir
hissettirebilmek Yani aslında insanlık
hangileri Neşe vardır Bu vardır saçma
aslında çok hissederek şey yapıyor Sen
o ilerledikçe ben bile Kendimi daha
Türkiye ye ve dünyaya Anadolu müziğe
olaylarına şu an şeyler geliyor zamansız
Muhtemelen ama biz amerikadaydım öptüm
oryantasyon zamanında Tamam dedim ben bu
gerçekten çocukluktan itibaren
Muhtemelen karşılaştığı Muammer
yok çünkü üniversiteyi ayrılmışız ve
atardım yüzükler Bunlardan biri olarak
mutluyum mutluyum yani seviyorum o oy oy
ilginç bir olay yaşandı bilinç gelişmiş
ve bir yandan da bunları yaparken 13
Euro'luk borcu denk eleştirdik yani Ama
arkadaşımız Yani biz de olan bir
olmamızın Evet Ee belki de en önemli
performansınıza hayranlıkla izledik ve
fazla vermeye başladım ve orada bir
tanıtan ve Aslında milyonlarca kişiye
hocamızın Entarisi ala benziyor
öğreniyoruz O yüzden de çok istiyoruz ki
bir şeyler yeni devam ediyor hayatımda
devam etti Aslında hiç böyle hayatında
sapan cümleleri doğru gider bazen her
arkadaşınızın şekilde herkesi bir baktık
de çok istekli bir şey yapıyor Sen bir
öyle böyle birleştirme değil uçan kuşa
konuda yer almak istiyoruz
önümüzde çok önemli festival ve
yaşında bir oyuncak bir enstrümanla ben
karar aldım Artık bir okumak istiyorum
size bir sonraki polifolia davet
düzenlemesini bütün dünya söyle Aslında
çok ön planda değildi ardından
nerede olduğunu bilmiyorum çünkü hep
benim bulduğum yerden bu sorunuma
seçmelerindeki gibidir başladım konuda
şeyi ama bazen de çok ciddi bir durum
sürü insanın hissederek yaptığı şey tek
ki tüm Türkiye O konuşmaya başladı
ilham olan milyonlarca S7 takipçi olan
yarışmalar davetler var toplam bütçesi
kendi hayatını kazanması gerektiği
böyle kendi kendime Duyduğum her şeyi
borcumuz var dünyanın farklı ülkelerinde
çocuk konularımız Olsun Türkiye'nin her
hayatım gerek aldım müzik pek geçirmeye
etmekten Kıvanç duyuyoruz o an hala
yok da buluşuyor Keşke bile
lise zamanı geldi lisede Mesela bizim
yani
söylemeye bir yandan da işte boş bir
YouTube'da işte 10021 50.000 100.000
çalmaya başlamıştım ve ardından ilginç
ana akım medyada kendine çok geniş yer
bilinciyle yetişen bir çocuktum ben yani
kocaman bir aile haline geldik
karar verdim ve bu asıyorlar Matematik
100 bin euro kuru olmuş 40 kişi işe
vursam
yerinde konulan
sorumluluklar vardır Bu da gerçekten o
derken biz kendimizi buralara attık Sağ
derken en çok sesli koro müziğin başka
için tiyatro çok çok önemliydi Ata
hazırlık yapabileceğiniz yazdı iki yıl
böyle bütün bedeninde şu an yankılanıyor
buldu çok önemli bir detaydır dr2010c ve
böyle tekrardan sahnelerde söylemiştik O
Bölümü bıraktık ve Yıldız Teknik
ailenin ekonomik rahatlığı falan yoktu
bir da işte yuvadır ama okulu ve hızlı
ekiple beraber yaklaşık kırkbeş kişi O
ama bütün bunları niye yapıyor mı acaba
olsun başkası bu
tutkunun soru bu aşkın algının gelin
tiyatro 90 diye düşün bu grubumuz vardı
Üniversitesi'nde bu okumaya başladım
ver bu
ama Bu üniversite eğitimi hiçbir etki
bir yönüyle bu atatürkiye daha doğrusu
[Müzik]
[Alkış]